as air travel picks up so too does
traveling by bus as 8 News Now reporter
Sally had a meal found despite the
pandemic many Latino families in the
valley are still choosing to stick with
their traditions and travel to Mexico
for the summer doofuses a bus company
that travels to many places such as la
fenix Utah and Mexico Jose Cabrera works
for the company he says coronavirus has
definitely had an impact in business we
remained open but a lot of buses did get
a canter so it was like 2 2 routes a day
Cavalera says in March many traveled to
Mexico due to the fear of Kobe 19 in the
valley yes I feel like a lot of people
are not afraid of anymore so they're
more out dr4 meal again with the
Southern Nevada Health District still
recommends avoiding non-essential travel
out of the country but if you do plan to
stay in one place nobody in sichting on
the buses and here at the Festa keeping
their buses clean is one of their main
priorities they are also checking every
passengers temperature and recommend
they wear a mask Jaramillo 8 news now